madame monsieur bonsoir 15h49 c'est à
15h49 cet après midi qu'une dépêche de
l'agencé centrale de presse acp mis fin
à l'inquiétude qui n'avait fait que
croître depuis 48 heures quant au sort
des otages de l'appareil d'air france
bloqué à téhéran par trois pirates de
l'air
ce soir tous les otages sont sains et
sauf épuisé il se repose à l'hôtel
hilton de téhéran les trois pirates de
l'air se sont rendus aux autorités
iraniennes
on ne connaît pas le sort qui leur est
réservé on ignore toujours leur identité
mais il s'était réclamé la nuit dernière
du mouvement islamique qui avait signé
il ya quatre ans l'attentât à paris
contre l'ancien premier ministre iranien
chapour bakhtiar
philippe rochon nous faire vivre jusqu'à
l'heureux dénouement les péripéties de
la journée il est 16 heures sur
l'aéroport de téhéran pour les 46 otages
restent encore à bord du 737 d'air
france c'est la fin d'un détournement
qui aura duré 48 heures mais tout le
monde est sain et sauf
les trois pirates de l'air ont fait
descendre tous les passagers et les
membres de l'équipage avant de plastique
et l'appareil mais seuls les explosifs
placés dans la cabine ont fonctionné le
consul de france à téhéran nous a
confirmé que tous les autres étaient
libres de l'avion on sait qu'à la
descente de l'avion des terroristes à
l'avant de l'avion
et ensuite il a été regroupé sur le
tarmac j'ai eu un moment de flottement
au cours desquelles les pirates ont été
servis aux fêtes et aux pasdaran
d'approché et en suisse si les ont
libérés
pourtant cette après midi on a cru au
pire
à 13h les pirates de l'air font sortir
un otage et pistolet contre la nuque se
livre à un simulacre d'exécution la
presse avec le feu vert des autorités
iraniennes est autorisée à filmer
l'événement destiné à montrer au monde
et à la france que le commando ne
plaisante pas ils ont affirmé qu'il
exécuterait un passager toutes les
heures l'un des pirates dans le cockpit
qui négocie avec les autorités
iraniennes par l'intermédiaire de la
tour de contrôle fait alors rentrer
l'otage à l'intérieur de l'appareil
un interprète mains sur la tête obtient
des pirates de l'air que le passager ne
soit pas exécutée et les invite à se
rendre
les pirates prépare alors le plasticage
de l'appareil avant de sortir avec les
otages afin que tout le monde à 6 à
l'embrasement du 737 d'air france à 23
heures hier soir les pirates de l'air
avaient déjà accepté de libérer les
femmes passagers et membres d'équipage
ou nombre de 11 avant de lancer un
ultimatum aux autorités françaises pour
7h30 ce matin les premiers témoignages
de l'équipage nous parvenaient alors sur
la façon d'agir des pirates de l'air
dans un téléphone à rnc décoller dans le
côtoyer l'autre en cabine en criant
c'est quelqu'un pour le trait
quelqu'un pour les tuer il arrivait en
cabine le couteau à la main et il me
disait encore d'accord mais alors avec
le prénom des femmes choquées par
l'événement ont dû être placées en
observation au dispensaire de l'aéroport
de téhéran en dernière minute on apprend
que les otages viennent seulement
d'arriver à l'hôtel leur contact avec
les autorités françaises sont réduits au
minimum
ils sont entourée d'importantes mesures
d'isolement mais pourrait être autorisé
à regagner paris demain à bord d'un
avion spécial